and book TV is back live in Nashville up
next
Joseph Beck describes the life of his
late father a lawyer who defended a
black man accused of rape in the 1930s
it's a story similar to that of Harper
Lee's To Kill a Mockingbird this is book
TVs live coverage of the southern
festival of books
Kirby's launches save Tuscaloosa
good afternoon welcome to the Southern
Festival of Books my name is Andy
Bennett
I'm your session host for today we're
here to hear from Sally Palmer Thomason
and Joe Madison Beck about their books
and afterwards they will be signing
their books in the signing colonnade
upstairs if you buy their books at the
Parnassus selling area the festival will
receive a part of the proceeds and
remember while the festival does have
some sources of income the main source
of income is donations from you and they
try and make it very easy for you to
donate you can donate on the festival
website you can donate on the Facebook
page you can use the festival app or if
you're a little old fashioned you can do
it in person
at the at the festival headquarters here
our first author who will be speaking is
Joseph Madison Beck he's an attorney in
Atlanta a Harvard University grad he
focuses on intellectual property
litigation particularly copyright and on
consumer products he's also a mediator
in a winner of too many awards for me to
mention here he also teaches at Emory
University School of Law so mr. Beck
will be speaking about his book my
father and Atticus Finch is an excellent
book and without further ado I'll turn
it over to mr. Beck thank you thank you
for coming
I how many of you read or saw the movie
to Kill a Mockingbird about what I
thought yeah it's a phenomenal
bestseller and I will tell you why I
call my book my father and Atticus
Mincher in a moment I'm going to read
from the preface because it gives me a
chance to give you a little background
on the book
and and my family my father did not sell
for his worth his sister told me that
and my mother did not disagree what does
that mean I wondered as a child only as
an adult that I trace it to a time
before my birth when as a young white
lawyer he represented a black man
charged with raping a white woman in a
small town in South Alabama my interest
intensified as time went on because this
was my father because like him I became
a lawyer and because people kept saying
his case could have inspired Harper
Lee's celebrated novel to kill the
monkey bird every time I talked about
that case people said that for a while
the thought that my father could have
inspired such a great novel it was
enough for me when even Harper Lee in a
lovely letter forged to me by our agent
acknowledged the quote obvious parallels
adding that she could not quote recall I
thought this case and that her work was
fiction I decided it's time to find out
more from myself now my manuscript was
accepted before publication of Miss
Lee's actual first book go set a
watchman which brought to mind the
question which is the real Atticus Finch
the beloved lawyer of tequila
Mockingbird or the bigoted guy in
Watchmen I can tell you from growing up
in Montgomery that they were both kinds
of Atticus in those days in Alabama and
many variations of them some said that
the Atticus of Mockingbird was fictional
it any was it was a fictional book but
that there was no such thing as a
southern white man he did that sort of
thing and that the racist in Watchmen
was the real southern white men that's
not true my father never subscribed to
racist materials never went to a white
Citizens Council or Klan meeting he
hated both organizations
he never called like people by the name
the n-word
he took farm produce as a fee and
and he did in fact courageously defend a
black man falsely charged with raping a
white woman in Troy Alabama in 1938 when
Harper Lee was 12 so if you miss the
Atticus of Mockingbird if you were sad
by the Atticus of watchman take a look
at this I'm on skipped through a few
pages just to give you a little more
feel of the case the judge called my
father in the town called Enterprise
Alabama which is in South Alabama away
from Troy maybe half an hour today back
then if the road was wet to half a day
and he asked my father to take the case
because the lawyers in Troy who were all
white men had quote conflicts you can
imagine and my father said of course he
would take the case and he did the judge
said read the Troy messenger the
newspaper and you'll find out what you
need to know and I'm going to read just
a little from that paper which I got
from the archives and Montgomery the
headline all-caps
Negro rushed to kill B prison after
attack Kilby prison was not in Troy it
was in Montgomery and the messenger
explained why they moved him first
sentence a wandering Negro
fortune-teller giving the name of CW
white was removed from the Troy Jail for
safekeeping following his attack on a
local white girl case sounds like it's
already over
according to paper it killed me the
messenger reported the Negro volunteered
a detailed confession of the attack and
the confession was reduced to writing
and signed in the presence of numerous
law enforcement officials a physician
called to attend the girl later
confirmed and in quoting from the
messenger the Negro had accomplished his
dastardly purpose well he didn't do it
and I'll tell you why I know that my
father met his client Charles white and
killed the prison mr. white was from
Detroit and Chicago
and he was not like the Tom Robinson you
remember from Kill a Mockingbird who was
very deferential polite some would say
obsequious Charles white from Detroit
and Chicago had a different attitude and
it showed up right away reading now from
way my father told me about their first
meeting Charles you say it didn't happen
the way she says but then why'd you sign
that confession you don't know they say
I don't sign they turn around and take
me straight back to Troy that night they
say I'm dying on a rope that night if I
find they promise I can stay here and
kill me until the trial and then come
back and serve up my sons my father who
promised mr. white five white men
Sheriff Deputy three others my father
maybe we can suppress the confession on
the ground it was coerced but if we
succeed the state may try to seek the
death penalty you see if you get a
confession in exchange for a promise of
life imprisonment you can't ask for then
that definitely that makes sense so he
says are you alright with a life
sentence and Charles says I don't want
to go to jail for something I didn't do
and my father says well if you plead you
at least be alive and Charles is not how
I want to live Charles I may be able to
bargain for Less time in life and make
you eligible for borough I'm not
entering a guilty plea I want that
confession suppressed well I think that
would be up to the judge whether to
suppress but do something for me lawyer
Charles white interrupting that was a
first meeting they came to be very fond
of each other but it wasn't first
meeting was a little low Harry now the
trial was in Troy Troy at that time was
infamous for having a statue of John
Wilkes Booth the man who murdered
Abraham Lincoln I present and my
congressman and the great civil rights
hero John Lewis in his book I wrote
about Troy where he was born a year and
a half after the trial
congressman Lewis recalled wondering as
a little boy why his mother said you
must be very very careful not to get out
of line with a white person by the time
he was ready for elementary school he
could see for himself why she warned him
because quote by then I had been Detroit
I went on July 13 about a month after
the arrest they got the trial pretty
fast back then judge the Troy messenger
reported the Negro as they preferred to
call him was brought to troy Wednesday
morning by a seven-member detachment
from the Alabama Highway Patrol these
men were joined by additional officers
stationed in Troy according to the
messenger there was no outward display
of proposed violence that Wednesday
during jury selection but as a
precaution Charles White was taken back
to kill be by the highway patrolman that
night and I right judge judge Parkes was
prudent to insist that Charles white be
escorted to and from Montgomery and that
the Highway Patrol be present during
jury selection there was high talk in
the crowd surrounding the courthouse
when the word got out that two Negroes
had been called for possible jury
service and compliance with the
Scottsboro ruling you remember the
Scottsburg trials were in Alabama few
years earlier and for a capital case you
had to have black people at least called
not necessarily served but called for
possible service judge parks but there
was let me just finish that sense the
talk subsided and a cheer went up when
it was reported that both Negroes had
been struck by the state of Alabama so
it got an old white male jury women were
not allowed on the jury back a capital
case the judge ordered the jurors kept
together for the evening under the
direction of special bailiff Henry Bauer
so as to avoid any taint of outside
influence in other words threats the
precaution turned out to be a wise one
that night darkness and liquor
emboldened some of the rough element to
slip the leash and prowl the streets of
joy of Troy looking for stray Negroes to
bully and assault
early in the morning of July 14 Charles
white arrived back in Troy escorted from
Montgomery's kilby prison I'm reading
now from the messenger by 14 members of
the Heil by Mohammed Patrol
the group was met outside by two more
patrolmen bringing the total to 16
these patrolmen remained surrounding the
courthouse throughout the trial and I
give judge parks credit for that he
insisted on what he called perfect order
he threatened to have people arrested if
it was a demonstration during the trial
and there were some angry reactions
especially when Charles white took the
stand I don't want to go over my time
because I'm this lovely author I'm all
right the prosecutrix the alleged victim
was a woman named Elizabeth Leiter she
was 20 almost 21 Charles White was a
middle-aged african-american man who
weighed about 250 pounds he was a
fortune teller and he was also a called
a healer a person who could help people
get well and he he was known as a
fortune teller and so elizabeth elijah
went to see him to get her fortune told
here's what she testified i got the
transcript once i got really interested
after my correspondence with harper lee
i'm some reading from her testimony and
i'm not going to read all of it because
despite what we've already heard in the
election I'm not some of it as a little
graphic and you can read it in the book
but I won't read the on TV after you got
through telling my fortune he told me to
come over to his side of the table where
he was seeing when I got over there he
pulled up my dress and took some kind of
salad and put it on me right down there
indicating the transcript recorded on my
private parts the solicitor prosecutor
did he do anything else to you that
Tuesday
she testifies he told me to get on the
bed he was going to fix me up and he
told me and I told him no he wasn't
going to fix me up there on the bed and
he got on top of me he pulled up my
clothes and pulled off one part of my
shorts I cried but it didn't do any good
I could feel something stinging down
there i stinging and a funny and burning
feeling down there and I asked him to
get off me but he would not do it state
asked the following question did you see
him undo his clothes i father objected
on the grounds that this was leading the
transcript recorded but there was no
ruling which meant they could go ahead
yes I saw and I know what a man's
private parts are yes I saw him do
something about that he got it out and
stuck it in nine I couldn't tell how far
because you see I was looking the other
way now that's if you're trying a case
you don't want on cross-examination have
all that repeated because it's already
been claimed perhaps the jury but on
cross-examining one of the three doctors
who testified the the testimony that
came out I'll read a little bit of that
but again I'll not read some of it by
dr. Stewart a Tulane Medical School
graduate here's what he said under oath
I was called to her house and I went
there and examined her on the bed they
see that is an important difference in
my father's case and to kill mockingbird
everything else is lines up pretty much
the same because in to kill a
mockingbird no doctor was called to
invest to examine Mayella if they had
have been one of course they would have
found she was not raped by Tom Robinson
but the doctor did investigate Elizabeth
Elijah the afternoon of the alleged
incident with a help of her sisters we
put her in the tub and gave her a douche
upon examining her private parts on that
occasion I found her hymen commonly
known as Maidenhead was very thick that
it had not been penetrated it had not
been broken that testimony was startling
to an all-white jury male South LM in
1938 so I've heard and it resulted in a
conference with the judge who could see
that this case was going to wind up
having to get a bit hung jury and being
retried and so he called my father and
the solicitor into his chambers sent the
jury out for a few minutes and tried to
work out a plea deal Charles white but
his heart wasn't buying it the judge was
going to give him a sense of life a
promise of parole and my father tried to
get him to accept it because he knew
what an Alabama jury was capable of
doing and if you look at the statistics
hundreds of black men were executed for
rape I did some research with the
Southern Poverty Law Center which is a
friend of mine and client gummy there
were some 400 black men executed for
rape in a very short period of time only
two white men and they were convicted of
both rape and murder it's
disproportionate and that has changed
we're a better country and Troy is a
better place it's a very nice town now
it has a good university there but back
then it was it was a very different
place Charles White testified and I've
got a lot of testimony in the book if
you're interested and it's I'm just
going to read you a little bit
my father saw me Charles white spoke in
a tone and with a demeanor he had not
previously seen because the solicitor
had been sternly warned by judge parks
and a whispered bench conference he
better not object to the questions
absent indisputable cause Charles
White's testimony proceeded without
interruption and is reproduced at nearly
its full length as recorded by the court
court I'm not going to read all that but
I would just tell you this when he
finished testifying he said that is all
that happened down there
I never did lock the door I did not put
any meself on her private parts I didn't
even put my hands on the white lady I
didn't put her down on the bed
the lady treated me nice she made me no
advances at all I treated her white
among the parallels besides the obvious
ones is is this Harper Lee wrote that
and this is quoting from her book
something unspeakable occurred between
Tom Robinson and Mayella and you may
recall from the book what it was may
Ella kissed Tom Robinson kissed a black
man and South Alabama that was
unspeakable I think something
unspeakable occurred here but it was not
right it was not even sex and to this
day I don't really know exactly but I do
know hi came out and my father stuck
with his client all the way to sadly the
electric chair yeah I can find it
quickly I'll read to you should it mark
this
well let's tell you from memory because
I pretty much remember it Charles White
was executed at a few minutes left at
midnight in Montgomery in June of 1939
for the black men were executed that
same day they went to the electric chair
humbly begging for forgiveness
Charles white protested that the
electrodes were too tight the people who
were but to kill him said don't you
realize you're about to die he's of
course and he said Jesus will Rucka
Jesus will recognize them innocent man
this day was raised last words so hope
you have some questions this I'll be
glad to try to answer thank you very
much mr. Begg fascinating fascinating
story next we're going to hear from Miss
Thompson who has written a book called
Delta rainbow the irrepressible Betty
Bobo Pearson Miss Palmer is from Memphis
not originally but at some point her
family realized their mistake and moved
to Tennessee not my whole family that's
not happen just your husband okay and
she's lived there for quite some time
she was a Dean at Rhodes College she's
also been a mountain climber a tennis
player and a yoga practitioner she
earned a doctorate in human aging in her
60s and this is her third book so she's
not a stranger to writing books and
probably not a stranger to talking about
them so after Ms Thomason discusses her
book we'll take questions for the
authors okay mr. Thomas thank you judge
and I just want to say what a privilege
it is to be here at the Southern Book
Festival I know that it is a wonderful
gathering of a lot of talent and they're
just pleased to be on the panel how many
of you have seen the movie Sulley has
anyone you know it's the movie about
Chelsea Sullenberger who was a US
Airways pilot who shortly after he took
off his plane in New York City lost
power in both engines of his aircraft
and he didn't have enough altitude or
time to return to the airport and in
less than four minutes he guided and
landed the plane on the Hudson River on
a frigid day in January in 2009 and
saved a hundred and fifty five lives now
why on a panel about civil rights am i
talking about an unbelievable area
nautical feet a couple of weeks ago in
an op-ed piece in The Wall Street
Journal Brett Stevens wrote about taking
his 11-year old son to see the movie
Sully while they were eating hamburgers
afterwards Bret's son said you know dad
famous people depend on what other
people think of them to be who they are
Sully just cared about whether he did
everything right that young lad clearly
articulated a distinct difference
between Fame and heroism so it was a
superb pilot but his action so showed
something more his history demonstrates
strong character anchored by a sense of
honour and virtues that go
wizard Chelsea Sullenberger wasn't out
for fame or to impress others he acted
not on what is popular or would enhance
his reputation he acted on a deeply held
conviction of what he knew was right
even though he had never had an
opportunity to practice or rehearse what
became his incredibly courageous act the
lives of both foster BEC Jo's father and
as he tells it in his book my father and
Atticus Finch and Betty Bobo Pearson as
her story is told in Delta rainbow
displayed courage and character in a
very different kind of situation but
they both displayed the same basic
impulse they acted on their own personal
convictions for doing what's at what was
right what they had to do they were not
out for fame or fortune or how many
tweets they might receive in a day both
Betty and foster did what they believed
was right in the situation where they
found themselves they displayed the kind
of courage Martin Luther King jr.
dreamed would come to pass someday when
men and women would be judged not by the
color of their skin but instead by their
individual deeds and actions and the
content of their character
Delta rainbow is a book about a woman
with remarkable character courage and
conviction it is a story of how and why
Betty Bobo Pearson a seventh generation
plantation born southerner whose roots
reach deep into the soil traditions and
social bonds of the Mississippi Delta
became one of the first
and one of the most outspoken leaders of
the civil rights movement in a
culturally and racially divided
Mississippi I want to read to you a few
paragraphs from the book to tell you how
her convictions started September 1955
it had been three weeks since the
discovery of Emmett Till's horrifically
mutilated body which had been beaten
shot in the head and sunk in the
Tallahatchie River a cotton gin fan tied
around his neck with barbed wire
when tills body was sent back to his
mother in Chicago she insisted on an
open casket and a public funeral Mamie
till Bradley wanted the world to see
what had happened to her young son the
world was aghast and in Sumner
Mississippi the initial shock and public
horror over the brutality of the murder
was palpable but Betty Pearson a sign of
one of the first white families of the
Mississippi Delta and at age 33 mistress
of rainbow plantation four miles south
of Sumner found one thing strange after
the first few days no one in town would
talk about the murder or the upcoming
trial assert a curtain of silence fell
most everyone she knew felt resentful
about the incredible amount of
international attention and vindictive
spot lake trained on her little town an
aggrieved undercurrent arose from a
general sentiment that the whole
procedure was unfair after all the
murder took place in Lafleur not
Tallahatchie County but the river
between the two counties
Bill's Pearson Betty's husband uncle was
the editor of the Sumner weekly and
Betty was so intrigued and in gasps what
was going on she got a press passed to
the trial for herself and a good friend
a good college friend named Florence
Mars she she had never been attended a
trial
in 1955 the courtroom was an all-male
domain as Joe was saying white women
could vote but by law they were excluded
from jury duty no black served on juries
although 4.3 percent of the Negro
population was registered to vote as the
two women were about to enter the black
back door the courthouse the entrance
for the press Harry Dogen an old family
friend and ex sheriff of Tallahatchie
County stopped Betty Betty he said you
shouldn't go be going to do this tile
you will be hearing things that no white
lady should hear Thank You mr. dogan for
his concern Betty pushed opened the door
and entered the large imposing building
which until that moment had been a mere
backdrop to her life walking into the
Tallahatchie County Courthouse on that
historic day in 1955 Betty Bobo Pearson
had her eyes blasted open betty grew up
in a segregated society and understood
how racist it was but her family her
friends everyone she knew treated
Negroes with decency and often with true
affection theirs was a paternalistic
racism a belief she felt was misguided
but never violent never vicious her
father would never harm much less much
less kill a negro she knew her father
her moral beacon in most areas
thought skin color did make a difference
now looking at the faces of the white
people in the courtroom
Betty realized for the first time in her
life how deep set their feelings were
she saw pure hatred who were these
people
they were neighbors citizens of the
surrounding counties Tallahatchie
Coahoma Lafleur sunflower they were
farmers laborers merchants tradesmen and
their women there were people she'd
lived with all her life yet
Betty realized she never before had
grasped the raw hostility these people
harbored who were they they were from a
different world Milam and Bryant swirled
a world of mistrust violence and hatred
towards Negroes a world very different
from her own never before had she
clearly understood how her privileged
heritage protected her for the first
time in her 33 years the quiet security
of Betty's Delta world was shaken she
saw beyond the facade of sensibility and
decency she'd known all her life
walking into the courtroom on that hot
September morning had thrown into sharp
relief the unspoken and largely
unexplained and at the attended the
country clubs and parties and sent their
children to the same colleges and the
poor whites who had not been college did
not own land and work for hourly wages
the one thing the two classes had in
common was a belief and their a
superiority to the Negroes the courtroom
receiving with sweat-drenched bodies was
packed
the first day as the jurors receded jury
selection took place Betty watched the
expressions on the faces and whispered
to her friend Flossie they'll never
convict even if the jury had been
impartial she realized that a conviction
after that trial which increasingly
resembled a scripted theater piece was
almost impossible on September 23rd 1955
after five full days of testimony from a
bevy of witnesses closing arguments from
both the prosecution and defense
attorneys and instructions from Judge
Swango the all-white male jury sitting
in the Tallahatchie courthouse in Sumner
Mississippi deliberated just over an
hour before acquitting both defendants
for the kidnapping and murder of Emmett
Till a fourteen-year-old boy from
Chicago after the trial a juror said
well it wouldn't have taken us so long
if we hadn't stopped for a soda the
verdict that verdict would shape the
course of Betty Bobo Pearson's future
what she witnessed during the trial
thrust her into a new and disturbing
awareness that would eventually tear her
away from her family make her suspect
suspect in her community and a stranger
from the man who had been the hero of
her known world her father Robert E Bobo
Betty had found her purpose and began to
act during the tumultuous 1960s there in
the Mississippi Delta she served on the
Mississippi Council on human relations
to promote dialogue between the races
she became a card-carrying member of the
n-double a-c-p
in the early 1960s she and her husband
bill built new well-designed housing for
the employees at rainbow
with electricity plumbing and a space
for a garden beside each house she took
rainbow employees to register to vote
which is with some very interesting
stories but anyway the Pearson's built a
swimming pool at Rainbow and gave
swimming lessons to every Negro child in
the area in their swimming pool she was
on the Mississippi Advisory Committee to
the United States Civil Rights
Commission and after and after a visit
to Washington and the Justice Department
tried to convince the local school board
to adopt a gradual program to end up int
aggression to avoid massive resistance
which she was a and she was rejected
outright
she taught literacy and life skills to
the inmates at Parchman prison she was
active on the board and Secretary of the
Mississippi Habitat for Humanity she was
co-editor excuse me co-chair of the
Emmett Till Commission when it was born
and she became estranged from many of
her longtime friends and nearly broke
her father's heart the incident that my
husband likes to tell happens when Betty
was a senior at Ole Miss in 1942 which
was during the war and there was an
acceleration and she had written a essay
for her philosophy class her senior
philosophy class now this is 1942 of why
the schools of mississippi should be
integrated well the professor who was
from the north was so impressed he
called betty in and he said can i submit
it to the rosenthal competition which
the winner will win a will be awarded a
full scholarship to Columbia School
graduate school there in New York City
Columbia University and she said oh sure
and she didn't really think much more
about it well about six weeks later the
professor called her in her into his
office and said
you have won the scholarship you can go
to the Columbia graduate school she was
ecstatic she could hardly wait to get
home to Clarksdale to tell her parents
and she ran into her daddy's Insurance
office and said daddy daddy guess what I
won a scholarship and he said no
daughter of mine is going to Yankee land
and or up to New York City well she was
devastated they argued they thought she
cried they slammed doors but family
loyalty was really too strong and she
just she couldn't defy her father and
she turned down the scholarship but she
had to figure out some way to to show
her daddy that she was a grown up person
and so she borrowed her mother's car and
drove up to Memphis and joined the
Marines the Marine Corps had just opened
up the there admission for women that
year so Betty became a rich marine after
interviewing Betty her family and many
of her friends and associates gene
Fisher who gene is the one that got me
into writing this book and I want to
recognize she's with us today but we sat
down together and said what what is what
are her character traits that really
what are the character traits that
really defy Betty because her story was
so remarkable and we sat down and made a
list and we put I'm not going to read
the whole list but the first one on the
list was you are here for a purpose now
there is a story behind that back in
1923
Lenora who is Betty's mother and her
Graham I'm sorry I'm jumping ahead here
that story when Betty was 18 months old
the family was returning from a brief
vacation in Florida in the Chevrolet
touring car and it was one of those
touring cars where there was an open it
had a top but everything was open and
then they had isinglass curtains that
would roll down if you wanted to be
protected but it was a it was a lovely
day and they had all the curtains rolled
up and they were coming home and they
got to UM Glendora and it was late in
the afternoon and there was a long
freight train coming by and so they had
to stop and they were waiting and they
were getting very anxious and very
impatient but they waited for the
freight train and as they I want to read
a little because it's just as the train
passed and the last freight car finally
passed and a crewman standing on the
cabooses rear platform wave for Leonora
that was Betty's mother to drive on
across she only got Midway
a second train hidden from view by the
passing train hurtled full-speed from
the other direction and crashed into the
car on the passenger side little Betty
flew out onto the cowcatcher
attached to the front of the oncoming
trains engine Betty's grandmother
severely injured lay unconscious on the
back seat in the front seat
Lenora four months pregnant sat rigid
jock gripping the steering wheel Betty's
grandfather killed instantly by the
impact played dead on the seat beside
Leonora as the Train hissed to a stop
one of the young boys who witnessed the
devastating crash saw a small body roll
off the front of the engine into a ditch
a few hundred yards away he ran to pick
up the crying toddler and carried her
back to the lady in the driver's seat
who screamed hysterically my baby where
is my baby
well in Laura Betty and her grandmother
and her grandfather's body
we're loaded onto the train and taken in
to Clarksdale where Betty's young father
who was had stayed home to bring in the
crop met them and then he got on the
train and took his mother on into
Campbell's clinic in Memphis and then
that night they realized that Betty
would was crying all night and they
couldn't get her to be quiet and so they
took her this is so interesting at the
time they took her to the dentist
offices which was the only x-ray machine
was in the city and took x-rays and
found that her collarbone was broken so
she went to Campbell's clinic where she
stayed a month but her grandmother
stayed three months and when her
grandmother was in the hospital she
could not grasp the bencher was dead her
husband was dead but when she came home
to Bobo she fell to pieces
utterly alone grieving for her husband
she begged Petty's parents to let the
little girl come down and stay with her
Betty's bed went downstairs it would be
years before it left her grandmother's
room and during those years
her grandmother put Betty to bed every
night and told her a story often she
spoke about the train wreck from which
Betty was miraculously saved after the
bedtime story
her grandmother insisted to Betty it
listened to Betty's prayers and told her
every night Betty God reached down and
plucked you from in front of that train
because he has something very special he
wants you to do with your life and Betty
did do something very special and still
doing she's 94 years old living in
California in a retirement home and
she's amazing her has all her wits about
us but in addition to Betty's leadership
for civil rights she and Bill were
founding members of the Piscopo Church
and Sumner Mississippi
and Betty held positions of leadership
in the local state and national
Episcopal Church
Betty Bobo Pearson had an insatiable
desire to offer fixing things and baking
them right but but what really was
interesting is that's not all she also
loves to have a good time create an
adventure create beauty to quote Carolyn
Webb a younger brand there in Sumner
rainbow the Pearson's plantation was
Betty's little piece of paradise it was
just the way Betty's heart is always
welcoming her garden her home her dinner
parties were magical in writing Betty
story I found her life to be like a like
a multi-faceted prism a rainbow throwing
light in many different directions a
dynamic leader an amazing counselor a
fabulous host and a master garden nerd
she seems to inherently know how to use
her wit charm intelligence social
position connections and stubbornness to
get what she wants and she too is a
woman when troubled is not afraid to
confront her own demons four years ago
when gene Fisher suggested I write the
Betty Bobo Pearson story I asked who's
Betty Pearson I had never heard her name
before I soon learned that Betty Bobo
Pearson's individual deeds and actions
and the content of character are a very
important part of the history of the
civil rights movement thank you thank
you
[Applause]
we have we have a little time for some
questions if you have a question would
you please come up to the black
microphone stand and ask away and
meanwhile I'm going to ask one well
while people are coming up miss Thomason
you you alluded to some repercussions
that Miss Pearson suffered for her
activities including breaches with the
family and so on
I was wondering if if a if you could
elaborate on that a little bit and and
bade mr. Beck if if your father I was
wondering if he suffered any any
repercussions either socially or to his
practice for representing this gentleman
uh yes they did suffer repercussions and
but one thing that Betty was very
fortunate in is that her husband who had
also been in the service he was a flyer
during World War two so they both had
lived out of the south and had had been
exposed to other attitudes and other
ideas was very supportive of her and so
if they weren't invited to a party or
someplace that if friends were just
shunning them he would ask her well do
you want to go and she said well no not
really police said well then forget it
you know but the thing about Betty is
that she did have such does have such a
strong feeling for family and so she
just quit talking about the the race
relations because they had one daughter
and she wanted her daughter to know her
grandparents and so they would see each
other so it was just a very tense but
workable situation that they
just had that they managed to live with
she had there are numerous incidences a
good friend of hers Oscar Carr who was a
also a planner there near Clarksdale
founded a bank about in 1955 656 and he
wanted to open it up and and give as
many loans to the black people in in the
area and help bring them up and he was
founded the bank and he was president of
the board and he then had gotten other
planters and other people leading
citizens there to be on the board of the
bank well some of the leading citizens
didn't like it and so he was he was
voted out of the presidency and Betty
couldn't reel was brokenhearted because
her brother was one of the people that
she found out had voted against it and
she couldn't understand it because her
brother and Oscar car had been best
friends it was a terrible breach in the
family but eventually Betty and Bob it
took years but they will they made up so
but there were there were incidents her
good flame Florence Mars who was
attended the Emmett Till trial was from
Philadelphia Mississippi and and I tell
you she she lost her business she helped
Philadelphia is where the young workers
from the north came down and were
murdered in Philadelphia and their
bodies were were buried and the Ku Klux
Klan it's all in the book but it the Klu
Klux Klan denied it and the big search
was on and Florence finally testified
and helped the FBI find them but it and
so and Betty was involved in that
mr. bet well taking a case like this is
not what you call a great way to develop
business and there were repercussions
initially people were willing to accept
the fact that there had to be a lawyer
for this man but the fact that my father
fought it as hard as he did the fact
that he paid for the transcript to the
appeal to the Supreme Court with his own
money
which he had very little office during
the Depression and it finally began to
wear on people I was born an enterprise
where his law practice was but we had to
leave and I wound up growing up in
Montgomery my father was drafted when he
was 37 years old I guess it was he was
blind in one eye it was payback and when
he got out of World War two and came
back to enterprise his law practice was
gone and he did what he could to make a
living working for what is now Fort
Rucker and eventually got a job with the
Veterans Administration in Montgomery
and that's where I grew up I want to
just if I may rather than talk myself
tell you why I think it turned out the
way it did with his practice of me
southerners first of all there were some
good white people in myself not just my
father and they are today of course and
they were when I talked about gradations
of prejudice there really were people
all over the lot from the Klan the
people who just were cowards to people
who tried to do the right thing but I
think the fact that he lost this case
when he was appointed would have been
acceptable
had he not continued to fight and here's
what I wrote is just a paragraph loss
the past down memory of the lost cause
shaped the spirit of the white South far
into the 20th century as the years went
by the principal reason for the civil
war to preserve slavery gradually became
an unacceptable reason for the war and
the loss of such a war all the more
unacceptable
an acceptable reason for the war had to
be found rebellion against an economic
tyranny ruthlessly imposed through
punitive tariffs became that reason loss
of such a war by men who were gallant
but vastly outnumbered the lost by an
agrarian culture to a predatory
industrial juggernaut became an
acceptable kind of loss among the better
class the idealized model for acceptance
of loss was robert e lee's dignified
surrender at Appomattox for the rough
element most of them born losers and
destined to remain losers throughout
their comparatively short and violent
lives loss in this life was natural and
because it was unavoidable it had to be
accepted Foster Beck had lost white men
who would have taken the law into their
own hands in the night of the crime and
would have imposed their own version of
justice we're now prepared to let foster
back be provided he was not stiff necked
that was their term and accepted his
loss and so I think the fact that he
continued to struggle with this case and
to fight and not give up was what ended
his law career and enterprise and forced
us to move to Montgomery thank you very
much thanks to both of you took a great
session remember you can purchase their
books at the Parnassus sales area and
they'll be signing right after this at
the the signing colonnade and we're
adjourned